the uncertainty is finally over Thailand
has a new king crown prince federal on
corn has now officially taken over the
throne from his late father King Bumi
bhula diya day Howard out wat da bruh I
would like to accept the invitation to
fulfill wishes of his majesty and for
the benefit of all the typos boom the
accession was long and coming but your
along corn was originally expected to
assume the throne the day his father
died in October but he asked it to be
postponed seeking time to mourn the new
king takes charge at a time when
Thailand is in a state of flux with
different political forces involved in
bitter fights some political insiders
fear his playboy image could make it
hard for him to navigate politically
uncertain waters as successfully as his
father did ties are already warming up
to the new king federal on corn has yet
to command the kind of adoration that
his father received from the people his
portraits are gradually finding a place
in Thai homes but finding a place in the
hearts of the people may not be as easy
for the new king